thank you very much Emma ladies and
gentlemen it's a real delight to be back
in Hillsdale again a part of normal
America you know this week is a heavy
travel week I'm going to be a Yale
University on Friday where I'm going to
do my best to point out to them that
they have a lot of changes they need to
make if they want to be known as the
Hillsdale of the Northeast and as a few
of you know I recently finished SCI
should maybe say I recently survived a
year as an inmate at the University of
Colorado at Boulder which is Berkeley
with snow right they in the fit of
madness they decided they wanted to hire
a conservative to come try out for a
year or actually three years is the idea
and I said I would try it for a year and
the longer boulder of course their their
idea of a conservative at Boulder is a
Trotskyite right and so after I got
there I thought this will be interesting
I'm kind of a gonzo guy I've been to
Berkeley though how hard could this be
and I had a lot of fun with them because
I've been get invited to all kinds of
liberal audiences who wanted to see this
exotic zoo animal in their midst and the
first thing I would tell them is you
know you have it all wrong I'm gonna let
you in on a secret I shouldn't but I
will conservatives love Boulder and they
would say really and and and we love
Boulder especially for the Greenbelt
that surrounded that you know the
environmentalists 30 40 years ago put in
a green bell to control growth and
preserve their quality of life and I
said the Greenbelt is the best feature
of Boulder I wish they had one in
Berkeley I mean the Greenbelt makes the
quarantine so much easier to enforce you
see it's easy to have our Tea Party
picket line set up around the perimeter
and you know when a liberals trying to
escape out in the real world we round
them up hand them a bag of fresh organic
kale and send them back into the village
and you guys just stay there it's
perfectly fine with us if you wreck
Boulder and Madison and Cambridge and
Berkeley if the rest of America is
relatively safer and then things usually
went downhill from there
and I had a great time actually I was
actually embedded for a semester in the
Environmental Studies department where
that was fun I'm going to begin tonight
with my conclusion and then show you how
I got to this conclusion my conclusion
is that decades from now I think
historians are likely to look back on
the hysteria over climate change today
the way we today look back on
prohibition as a comic misadventure that
shows the harsh limits of political
enthusiasm directed against basic facts
of nature and society however and here's
the complicating part whether we'll
avoid committing the folly of embracing
the energy equivalent of prohibition is
still undecided I'm thinking that we
won't but it may be a close-run thing
for a very simple and elemental reason
and that's the environmental movement
which is deeply authoritarian at its
core has an unquenchable will to power
that cannot be satisfied and will not be
denied and so the fate of this is in the
balance as albor might have said in a
different way and as I say we can't tell
yet whether this will be looked back
upon as a comic misadventure or a tragic
misadventure now the formal title of my
speech this evening is a funny thing
happened on the way to global warming
and I love this title I wasn't sure the
weather Tim Casper and Doug Jeffrey
weren't being mischievous a little bit
thinking that my you know double chin I
was starting to look like Zero Mostel
you need to be a little older to get
that reference I know but I do like the
title but actually three funny things
have happened on the way to global
warming three of them first warming
stopped imagine that second the policy
agenda of the climate East is as I call
them or an even better term for the
climate Crusaders is Therma get a
night's
I didn't think of that that's Britain's
Lord Monckton came up with that netting
that is really good but the policy
agenda the climate Easter's has been
revealed to be completely absurd and
I'll walk you through that here in a
moment but there's a corollary to that
as a thought experiment
even if catastrophic human caused
climate change turned out to be true
environmentalists are the last people we
would want to put in charge of dealing
with the problem
full-stop when I'm in a mischievous mood
I did this at Boulder a lot I would say
to environmentalists I said look let's
just quit arguing about the science it's
really tedious but only conservatives
could fix this you know and that was
always fun
the third funny thing that has happened
is something that no one predicted
there's been some talk about it today at
lunch and other presentations and that's
the revival of the oil and gas energy
sector through the technological
revolution of directional drilling and
Rock massaging that's what I call
fracking rock massaging no one saw this
coming
as recently as 10 years ago all the
official forecasts including of a lot of
the energy companies exxon mobil's
annual forecasts British Petroleum they
all predicted continuing declines in oil
and gas production in the United States
and by the year 2020 not far off from
now the United States was predicted to
be importing 20% of its natural gas from
guess who and now that has all changed
and the important thing is this if the
political this all happened very quietly
out in the private sector as was
explained at lunch today and if our
political class in Washington and the
media had known this was going on they
surely would have done something to stop
it and that's what they're trying to do
now of course but there's too late as
too much momentum his aren't markets and
innovation wonderful so let's take these
in order first about the warming
stopping between roughly 1978 and 1998 a
20 year period the catastrophic global
warming scenario seemed to have some
evidence on its side during that roughly
two decade period the global average
temperature rose suddenly and sharply by
about four tenths of a degree Celsius
and conveniently that was right in
line with what a lot of the newfangled
computer climate models predicted but
then as we say the funny thing happened
it suddenly stopped
even though greenhouse gases kept rising
the atmosphere at a steady rate now at
first the pause as it's come to be known
could be plausibly attributed to random
year-over-year variation what ordinary
people call weather or what the
scientists call a basically chaotic
climate system that they will quickly
acknowledge they don't fully understand
in a couple of other one-off events like
the Mount Pinatubo eruption in 1992
which changed some things but now we're
going on in almost eighteen years really
almost twenty years depending on how you
treat 1998 which I won't do now but
we're going on seventeen eighteen up to
twenty years without any warming and all
the models are starting to be falsified
the actual temperature record is now
falling below 95% of the of the climate
model temperature forecast in other
words 95% of the projections are proved
to be wrong because there isn't just one
by the way if you get into this misery
there's several dozen different computer
climate models generating a different
temperature forecast and the record of
the last two decades is now falling
below the lowest forecasts for the
future with all but about one or two of
the models are basically still in line
if this goes on for another five to ten
years a hundred percent of the models
will be shown to be wrong because the
basic theory says we should be
continuing to increase about two-tenths
of a degree per decade as long as
greenhouse gases are going up at the
rate they are and it's not happening it
is becoming the biggest embarrassment
for the scientific consensus since
Piltdown man you know that it was
somebody today asked Ken Greene about
made reference to the email scandals of
the East Anglia climate unit in 2009
there's one of those emails from
climatologist Kevin Trenberth he's one
of the deep dish climate alarmists Ted
Boulder and he said in one of those
emails and I'll quote him here he said
it was a travesty
that climate scientists could not
explain the pause that's five years ago
now and we're still pausing
they've been scrambling ever since to
offer a whole series of explanations
and-and-and the International or the
Intergovernmental Panel on Climate
Change the UN's IPCC as Ken mentioned
today they're doing their best to paper
this all over and twist and and and
shout and do everything they can to try
and cover up the fact that their scheme
is failing and you made my favorite
moment in the media there's only a
couple people in the media who covered
this honestly one of them I should give
a fair credit to is Andy repkin at the
New York Times who's pretty
environmentalist and sympathies but
pretty much plays this issue straight
good for him the other is the Economist
magazine which is otherwise very much
within the so-called consensus and they
wrote back in March quote if climate
scientists were credit rating agencies
climate sensitivity would be on negative
watch good for the economists now I'm a
glutton for punishment so it was why ken
and I are friends like yes I I read
through a lot of the latest IPCC report
on climate science came out about a year
ago the science report is you know 1,300
pages long or something in particular if
you're a glutton I recommend reading
chapter nine it is called evaluation of
climate models its 218 pages long 218
pages a very small print and Ken said
you can't quote it actually you can't
even read it it's not quite true with it
it is it is it takes a long time to
figure out what's going on you know
these days if the complaint made to
people like me and Ken is if we say the
word uncertain or uncertainty it's bad
faith a chapter on computer climate
models to meet you in it has the word
uncertain or uncertainty 173 times in
218 pages and it uses the term error or
errors 192 192 times I'll describe a
couple these errors and uncertainties
for you what they try to persuade you is
if we keep twisting the knobs on these
computer models long enough we can get
to match up with
happened except you keep going and
realized they can't even do that and
they admit these things very grudgingly
and talk about how certain areas of
essential knowledge of how the climate
system works continue to really elude
our grasp
in particular clouds clouds and water
vapor that's really important to the
story so let me quote one quotable part
which goes like this there remain is the
quote now there remains significant
errors on the model simulation of clouds
next sentence it is very likely that
these errors contribute significantly to
the uncertainties in estimates of cloud
feedbacks and consequently in the
climate change projections and if you
really read it carefully in ten times
you realize that they admit that it's
possible that clouds they admit that
clouds could cancel out most of the
forcing effect of greenhouse gases this
is what people like Richard Lindsay have
been saying for a long time now I'm not
just a glutton for reading his reports
when they come out I went to the trouble
of finding some of the drafts leading up
to it you could get people to leak these
things to you and one of the last drafts
before the final report came out had
this sentence in it in that same chapter
nine which I thought was quite curious
here's the quote the ability of a
climate model to make future climate
projections cannot be directly evaluated
let that sink in for a minute
we can't even evaluate our models that
sentence was dropped from the final
report I'm sure someone said hey wait a
minute we can't say that instead after a
lot of mumbly mouths stuff about you
know why the pause is happening and
we're still confident that we want to
keep playing with our knobs this
sentence appeared instead this one's
even better actually when you think
about it quote these projections were
not intended to be predictions over the
short timescales for which observations
are available to date translation pay no
attention to our models behind the
curtain
just trust our judgment that the end is
near you know the great social scientist
James Q Wilson used to say that social
scientists should quit trying to predict
the future because they can't even
predict the past I think the climate
science community might well heed that
advice where is the missing heat if you
want to just go from the Orthodox
climate theory most of the climate East
is say it's going into the deep ocean
and well that's a plausible theory we
have very little data to substantiate it
and some data that's coming in recently
suggests that it's not happening and we
have even less understanding about how
that might play out in the future other
explanations for the pause include
unusual western Pacific wind patterns
I'm not making this up
aerosols which means you know higher
level particulates in the atmosphere and
my favorite increased solar variation
there's this thing up in the sky called
the Sun you may have seen it and what's
strange is it not a lot of people I mean
not just ordinary citizens who wonder
about this but scientists even would say
you know what about variations in solar
radiation sunspots and the climate
science community is always says no and
their official models if you read them
say it's a very tiny factor in any
variation in the climate and so for them
now to say solar variation is driving
the pause that's interesting isn't it
how convenient we're up now to something
like fifty seven possible explanations
for the pause I think they're pulling
that off a ketchup bottle right now the
pause and the admittedly persistent
limitations and errors of the computer
climate models resemble in my mind the
kind of anomalies that the philosophic
historian Thomas Kuhn famously explained
should constitute a crisis for a
dominant scientific theory and while the
climate East is refused to acknowledge
it this crisis is causing some serious
second thoughts about the basic question
of climate sensitivity in other words it
can give a short primer on this this
afternoon if you were here it's true
that greenhouse gases are a the
temperature a little bit and the climate
sensitivity models will always say
and always been rigged to say it's going
to do a lot and there are more and more
studies published in the peer-reviewed
scientific journals saying no what we
have been six obsess systematically
overestimating climate sensitivity it's
much much lower than we've been led to
believe and really what this comes to is
this is really an on problem we're not
the kind of problem we've been told
about but instead of confronting the
fact that their cause has foundered
mostly of its own dead weight the
climate tasters have ratcheted up new
levels of bad faith and grasping
authoritarianism that's the technical
terms of what they're doing I think the
result of the latest catalogue of
exaggerated claims and appalling cliches
is it was endless but the most egregious
one is one that I'm sure many of you
heard of or seen it on TV it's the
ubiquitous refrain that 97% of all
scientists believe in climate change by
the way they even use that word believe
like as an article of religious faith
which i think is also a curious thing
and it's not just climate advocates NASA
a federal government agency says they
have a webpage that says that phrase 97%
of scientists believe in climate change
that's our government speaking now and
of course the political suggestion
behind us is if 97% of scientists
believe in climate change then therefore
they must all agree with the
environmentalist agenda to suppress
energy so where did this 97% figure come
from when you explore its lineage it
turns out to be about as convincing as a
chicago election the most no you can't
believe that right the most prominent
form of it comes from a paper by a
professor in australia named john cook
at the university of queensland and he
published this paper in obscure journal
and it's just rocketing around and
become the big thing and what the study
purported to do was review the abstracts
of 11,000 climate science articles not
just stop right there
important they say abstracts no one's
going to read 11,000 climate articles
even a whole team of graduate students
is not going to read through 11,000
science articles so they read the
abstracts fair enough the abstract is
always that one paragraph summary
the head of any academic journal article
well here's the abstract to the cook
paper which no one in the media seems to
have the wit to read for themselves
first sentence we find that sixty six
point four percent of abstracts
expressed no position on anthropogenic
global warming comma let's stop right
there 2/3 66 but two-thirds the papers
express no opinion on human-caused
global warming let's keep going thirty
two point six percent endorsed
anthropogenic global warming zero point
seven percent rejected it and zero point
three were uncertain okay so that means
a third of those papers had an opinion
on human-caused global warming so the
next sentence says this among abstracts
expressing a position on human-caused
global warming 97.1% endorsed the
consensus positions that humans are
causing the warming somehow this has
become 97 percent of all scientists when
it's 97 percent of a third of scientists
or you might put it this way you could
just as easily say 66 percent of
scientists publishing the field have
expressed no firm opinion on the matter
or still another way to think about it
is this is the grandfather of all
simple-minded tautologies among all the
scientists who agree with the consensus
or all the acai entities and would be an
adequate way of saying it now initially
professor Cooke refused to share the
data with anybody else to review the how
they've been coded and whether they
matched up that's always a bad sign
right there isn't it but of course in
the modern world with things planted on
internet databases somebody found the
data and lo and behold some of the
articles turned out to be not really
about climate science at all one article
that was a build as a science article
was about US media coverage of climate
change issues strangely in those 11,000
papers was not a single one from Richard
Lyndon of MIT one of the most prominent
he's the most prominent skeptic in the
climate science community who has been
publishing on the subject since 1961
none of his papers are included somehow
and yet this phrase I mean you can't go
anywhere now without seeing it or you
know get on the Center for climate
progress without sement 97% of
scientists agree or believe in right
well it's clear that the climate
establishment has become as narrowly
intolerant as any Department of Gender
Studies on a college campus and for much
the same reason what this really masked
as a will to power as I said at the
beginning there's a pretty good new book
out on American environmentalism called
climate of crisis by Emory University
historian Patrick allit is it not a bad
book I reviewed it last week in the
Weekly Standard and he thinks that the
next generation of scientists like
previous generational successions will
seek to overturn the conventional wisdom
of the current community I hope he's
right about that I understand the
academic dynamic but I'm not so sure I
don't think it's like history where each
generation of historians likes to say
the previous one was all wrong about the
American Founding or something right I'm
not sure it works that way in science I
think he underestimates how deeply the
environmental movement is invested in
the idea of catastrophic climate change
but that leads me to the second funny
thing that happened on the way to global
warming and that's they still in
complete realization of the sheer
absurdity of the climate policy agenda
now global warming was always the dream
issue for environmentalists because it
gave them license to commandeer the
entire energy sector of the entire world
and as energy is the master resource
that enables all other resource use it's
I would say the platform for material
human progress itself getting control of
energy is the commanding height of human
civilization but what they have proposed
is a transformation of the world's
energy system so sweeping and so
unrealistic that it would make King
Canute blush with embarrassment and here
I'm gonna have to walk you through a few
numbers I tend not to like to try and do
numbers in a talk like this because it
can be hard to follow I didn't want to
do PowerPoint the same reason this can
because numbers on the screen or even
worse in some ways you can't see them
and so I'm going to try and as
with me on this and I'll make this as
straightforward and comprehensible as
possible but you begin with this the
target of climate policy orthodoxy is an
80% reduction 8 0 80% reduction in
carbon dioxide emissions worldwide not
just the United States worldwide by the
year 2050 80% reduction by 2050 I call
it for shorthand the 80 by 50 target now
no one actually knew what this meant in
practice till I a few other people got
after it and you know you throw out
these large 80% of something and you
know 6 billion tons of emissions what
does this all mean it's hard to know
when you're throwing around these my
eyes glaze over numbers right well
here's how the how this works and I'll
translate this into real terms for you
the big round number you start with is
that it's changed a little bit but this
is good enough for our purposes here the
figure that the Department energy starts
with from a few years ago is the USC the
US will just use the US for now us a
minute about 6 billion tons a year of
carbon dioxide that's about 20 tons per
capita 20 tons for each of us now 20
tons sounds like a lot one little fact
that's fun is each one of us
individually exhales about 800 pounds a
year of carbon dioxide just from
breathing so you can see you're in a
nice downpayment on the way to your 20
tons just from breathing in and out so
that does that's not only that much if
you think about it then 20 tons
now an 80% reduction actually 83% and
the waxman-markey bill but don't worry
about that it takes us down to about 1.1
billion tons or if you want to just keep
it simple we're going from 6 billion
roughly and round numbers to about 1
billion now the first threshold question
I got curious about was when was the
last time the United States carbon
dioxide emissions were that low you
can't figure this out takes a little bit
of work it's not that hard you got to go
through the historical data tables that
are available and the answer you come to
is that the US last admitted
billion tons of carbon dioxide around
1910
maybe 1905 that's another calculation
someone else did that's pretty good in
1910 the US had only 92 million people
and if you do the math that meant we had
about 10 tons per capita emission so but
half of the level we are today with 92
million people however in the year 2050
if the Census Bureau is right we're
going to have about 420 million people
in this country what that means is if
we're going to have to stay under a
billion tons of total emissions for the
whole country each one of us will have
to lower our per capita emissions to 2.5
tons a person that's 1/4 of the amount
our great-great-grandparents emitted a
hundred years ago when by the way their
incomes were you know a fraction of what
they are today didn't have air
conditioning didn't have flat-screen tvs
didn't have a lot of refrigerators
didn't have many cars you're starting to
see where this is going I did look up
when was the last time the US was I
think by the way u.s. carbon dioxide
emissions may have never been that low
even in the colonial era when we were
only burning mostly wood and some whale
oil but from the data tables I was able
to figure out that the last time we were
at 2.5 tons per capita of carbon dioxide
emissions was 1875 there is a technical
name for this kind of policy target that
name is Looney Tunes this is not going
to happen in 36 years or whatever that
you know time frame is off from now
right there are a few nations that
emitted 2.5 tons per capita that we can
look at as possible models believes
Mauritius Haiti Somalia you get the
picture desperately poor countries admit
at that level because they're poor by
the way this is also something that any
sensible person understands really poor
countries what are their environmental
records right overall they're really
really bad their waters terrible they
cut down all their trees they over graze
their land they pollute
water terribly you don't want to be that
kind of country that's not how you solve
environmental problems you need to get
rich to solve environmental problems Bob
what about those enlightened Europeans
well the best countries in the world
that are industrialized and wealthy are
France and Switzerland they both get
about 90% of their electricity from
nuclear power and hydropower which are
have no greenhouse gas emissions and
their compact countries right people
don't drive a long way in France or
Switzerland they don't have to ship you
know Paris to Lyon that's a short drug
you know don't ship goods very far in
that country agricultural goods or any
other here we ship stuff from Chicago to
Los Angeles right we ship things a long
way we're not the same but but even
there those two countries with all their
super green policies their per capita
emissions are 6.5 tons per capita you
know two and a half times the target
we're told we have to meet by the
environmentalists I could go on with
this and I might go just a little bit
more to give you a little bit more grasp
of this I'm still on sort of large
numbers right per capita all the rest of
that give you one more example of how
crazy this is
remember our targets about 1 billion
tons
now when the Department of Energy does
these assessments and gives us our
emissions inventory they break the US
economy into four basic sectors
residential our houses and apartments
and condos and whatnot commercial office
buildings industrial our factories and
transportation how we all move around
and move our things those four sectors
so remember 1 billion tons for the whole
country in 2050 all four sectors right
now the household sector just just
living at home making our coffee we emit
1.2 billion tons of co2 just from our
houses that's you know 20% higher than
the target for the whole country for
everything 36 years from now when we're
going to have a whole lot more people
now if we have the same pie in 2050 is
today and it could change but it's worth
using the same pie or same share
it means the household sector in the
year 2050 would have to emit no more
than about 205 million tonnes instead of
the 1.2 billion we emit today so I
decide to break that and down even
further figure out some interesting
things how many of you here who have
houses some of your students I know how
many of you have natural gas in your
houses for your furnaces yeah a bunch of
you right and that's that that's the
state of the art for new houses it's
much more efficient than electricity
lectric heating
remember I said two hundred five million
tons for the household sector in 2050
for everything today co2 emissions just
from natural gas use in our houses
before you flip a single light switch
237 million tons so our natural gas use
today is already higher than what it's
supposed to be in 2050 for the whole
household sector for all uses I mean the
Department of Energy projections they're
all saying this is this is a joke right
you know household use of energy
overalls can be much higher by 2030
that's as far as their projections go
right now is 2030 we're supposed to be
building something like 40 million
residential households in the u.s. I can
go on with this I have sort of gone down
and drilled down even further to point
out that if you try and do this through
conservation that's what some of my
friends of National Resources Defense
Council say let's just do conservation
and we really going to weatherize the
entire housing stock well it turns out
you can't do that if you you try and if
you run through the numbers what you
find is you don't even have enough
electricity to run your hot water heater
forget flat-screen TVs or refrigerators
same things troop transportation I'll
just give you one last thing here and
then I'll stop with numbers right now
our cars and trucks consume about 180
billion gallons of motor fuel a year now
again if the transportation sector is
going to stay within our total emissions
budget we'd have to shrink that down at
best to about 30 billion gallons well
the last time we consumed 30 billion
gallons for our cars and trucks and
transportation was 1930
if the entire if every single person in
the country drove a Toyota Prius in 2050
we'd still overshoot the transportation
sector emissions target by 40 to 50
percent and I have left out airplanes by
the way their planes are actually small
of our total but it's like five percent
of our total fuel consumption is
airplanes and no one's yet figured out
how you're going to electrify an
airplane we may Electrify cars someday
better than we're doing now Tesla's are
kind of fun but they're not very
practical nor are they affordable for an
ordinary human being so the clear
implication of this target is that we
have to replace the entire fossil fuel
energy infrastructure over the next
three decades that's what they're
telling us to do and not just the United
States but for the whole world even if
it could be done at all and I think it
can't there would be a
multitrillion-dollar proposition let me
share with you an interesting couple of
sentences from the International Energy
Agency they're folks in based in Paris
they do really good international energy
analysis they published a world forecast
every year that's really good and they
were discussing this problem and they
said this they make reference share by
the way to the 450 parts per million
target that that's part of climate or
remember I'm about to explain that now
but I don't think you need to know to
understand the what the sentence means
here's the quote from the IEA in 2008 in
other words the OECD countries that's
they know the industrialized countries
of the world the OECD countries alone
cannot put the world onto the path to
450 parts per million even if they were
to reduce their emissions to zero pause
there what they just said that sentences
the United States Europe Japan could
disappear off the face of the earth and
you the world would still not come close
to the target of climate orthodoxy why
well because China and India are growing
and Brazil and and you know Africa would
like to develop so with the rest of Asia
and by the way they're doing that mostly
with coal
come back to the point in a moment let
me continue with what the IEA said even
leaving aside any debate about the
political feasibility of the 450 policy
scenario it is uncertain whether the
scale of the transformation envisaged is
even technically achievable as the
scenario assumes broad deployment of
technologies that have not yet been
proven the technology shift if
achievable would certainly be
unprecedented in scale and speed of
deployment this is remarkably direct
language for one of these international
bureaucracies and when this came out
guess what happened all hell broke loose
from the climate community and they
denounced the IEA and essentially they
force them to retract a statement there
next year they said all we can do it you
know they went back to the usual happyto
cliches of unicorn flopsweat and all
other you know banana peels all the
other things we can power the world with
they got hammered for that bit of
honesty because that's what the climate
campaign is like one thing that's
important to understand is that energy
energy transitions are very long that
was true with past energy transitions
from wood to coal from coal to oil and
now we're making a transition in this
country and others to natural gas
transitions are long for the same reason
that the turnover in our housing stock
tends to be long our energy systems
represent large long-term fixed capital
investments and you don't generally
replace large infrastructure before its
useful life is over that's economically
wasteful
it'd be like remodeling your whole house
because you don't like the color in the
kitchen in the bathroom or replacing
your two-year-old refrigerator with a
new model because it's ten percent more
energy efficient but that's the energy
equivalent of what the climate East is
want they want a multitrillion-dollar
outlay to replace energy systems that
are not worn-out and importantly whose
conventional air pollution has already
been reduced to the vanishing point now
I'm pretty sure in fact I would bet a
lot on this that both Robert Bryce and
Mark Mills tomorrow who are absolutely
fantastic they're going to go through
some of the comparative defects of the
current menu of alternative and
renewable energy supplies that make the
environmentalists wake up happy in the
like wind and solar and biofuels suffice
it today as a placeholder till you hear
from Robert and Mark tomorrow
is their vastly more expensive and not
scalable to global or even national
needs and in many cases have enormous
negative environmental trade-offs of
their own can mention a few today about
ethanol that's true of wind and solar as
well meanwhile what is going on is as in
so many other domains the Obama
administration's not waiting I'm going
to take executive action the Supreme
Court in 2007 improvidently told the EPA
that yes you can regulate greenhouse
gases under the Clean Air Act a law
written for a completely different
problem with tools that are completely
inappropriate to this problem even if
you think it is a joint a giant problem
and so they have announced this very
complicated and convoluted plan to
regulate the electricity sector in the
United States and as these things go
it's you know 675 pages of the main plan
and then the 400 page impact assessment
that analyzes the costs and benefits and
it's very hard to understand they
emphasize their flexibility in
announcing this we're going to and each
state has a different target based on
its carbon intensity because you know
some states like I've never looked at
Michigan but Ohio and Indiana get about
80% of their electricity from coal
Washington states gets almost no none of
their electricity from coal because they
have all those old nuclear power plants
and all those big dams on the Columbia
River so different states have different
electricity profiles and they're trying
to take this into account although of
course that's where the mischief begins
because appear Kratz flexibility today
is their mandate tomorrow right so
there's all this language about we'll
have a menu of options because by the
way without getting the legal parts of
this they can't directly say to an
individual coal plant you have to shut
down or you have to reduce your
emissions by some unrealistic amount
because that would fail a legal
challenge but they can do it indirectly
and bureaucrats are great at that
what does menu of things you can do
conservation increase your heat rate and
maybe even they say a cap-and-trade
steam a scheme between different states
and different regions and although you
know again if
you peel us apart very carefully it
looks like a wealth transfer from red
states to blue states who knows what it
will cost but the EPA claims with a
straight face that this scheme will
reduce everyone's energy costs now I've
been asking the question
there's several states this one student
this afternoon made a question about
states with renewable portfolio
standards this is where we mandate
you're going to get your electricity
from windmills and solar panels you
can't point to a single state with a
renewable portfolio standard that
whether energy costs have gone down
quite the opposite although states have
higher than average electricity rates
when Gina McCarthy the head of the EPA
was announcing this back in June I'm
watching all these unbelievable claims
and I just kept thinking when is she
going to say if you like your utility
rates you can keep your utility rates
that sense of what she's saying I was
unbelievable contrast that typical
bureaucratic dishonesty with Barack
Obama himself I'm going to give him a
little credit for honesty here back in a
2008 campaign he said this some of you
may remember this quote under my plan of
a cap-and-trade system
electricity rates would necessarily
skyrocket businesses would have to
retrofit their operations that will cost
money they will pass that cost on to
consumers and quote I don't see why we
shouldn't take him at his word now let's
give you one more one of the EPA fact
sheets again I glutton I read through
these crazy things it's you know I have
no life I guess one of the EPA fact
sheets says the following we expect the
quote here we expect extensive and very
rapid changes in the structure of the
power sector again once you fight your
way through the fog of bureaucracies and
learn how these things work you
understand what they're really proposing
is to make the EPA a Federal Public
Utility Commission and they're going to
regulate the electricity grid now now
the way the Clean Air Act works in
shorthand is a states are supposed to
come up with plans to implement it in
their state that made some sense for
conventional air pollution for a lot of
reasons I won't bore you
now once this rule is made final I think
next June it becomes final the clock
starts ticking and states are supposed
to submit a plan within a year of how to
satisfy these targets EPA is set out for
them that's a high order there's all
kinds of problems State Department's
Environmental Quality actually don't
have jurisdiction over electricity grids
so they're going to have to get the
public utilities Commission's and these
interagency task force and the
bureaucracy is going to be wonderful
I am wondering in hoping especially in
light of the election results that there
going to be a number of states who said
no to Obamacare we'll say no to the EPA
because by the way the fall back of the
Clean Air Act has always been if you
don't do a plan we'll come in and do a
plan for you and impose it on your state
it's so much better if you do it because
you're closer to things well you know if
20 states said no we're not going to do
this and the EPA yes has the legal
authority to come in and say we're going
to pose a plan on you then but I think
it would break the EPA to try it and
I'll bet they're terrified of that idea
which is why I'm going to be encouraging
governors and state legislators to say
no we're not going to do this there's
going to be a legal challenge and so
it's be limbo for a while but I think
that's the right no we're not going to
do this finally on this then we'll move
to a conclusion questions the target
emissions reduction is just 30% from the
electric power sector which is only one
of which only accounts for what 35% of
our emissions in the u.s. overall I
forget in other words you're talking
about maybe if it really worked a 10%
reduction in total greenhouse gas
emissions if it all worked according to
plan
the EPA touts enormous benefits from
doing this will reduce ozone will reduce
particulate pollution of course that's
what the Clean Air Act does already and
it's happening very fast so they're just
proposing to do the same thing they're
already doing only in a different way
and more onerous there's one thing
conspicuously missing from the claims of
benefits in the EPA's assessment they
make no claim that their regulations
would affect climate change and that's
because it won't leave if you actually
and I you know I try to get a couple
reporters to try asking at the White
press but they would just punt to the
EPA but the question would be if you run
vocal assume this plan works like a
charm and you meet all those emissions
targets what difference would it make if
you ran that through the computer
climate models for the year 2100 the
best guess is it would change the
temperature by two one hundredths of one
degree which is actually you know inside
the margin of error in other word makes
no difference right so why are we doing
this well oh by the way and even Al Gore
someone asked if I want somebody Al
Gore's that someone's gonna mention Al
Gore to said I wasn't sure I would but
he described the EPA proposal quite
revealingly as symbolic Al Gore in a
rare moment of honesty an environmental
movement is delighted about this after
saying they didn't want to do it this
way because they love bureaucracy and I
think what they're hoping is as once you
cement in place the EPA's Authority a
30% reduction can be ratcheted up to a
50% reduction and then a 75% reduction
and then maybe a hundred percent at some
point all on the authority of the EPA
alone bypassing Congress let me move
towards a conclusion in one last quick
point my third funny thing which I can
do in just one paragraph actually here's
what the point of this middle part of my
analysis the second funny thing is the
cruel irony for the climate tiers is
that the worse the dimensions of climate
change the more farcical are their
proposed remedies so you know we may try
to close 500 coal plants or they're
still a little over 500 coal plants but
right now there are thousand coal plants
under construction elsewhere in the
world and my guess is were going to
build under 5,000 of them at least the
next 20 years because as the Chinese put
it - Al Gore in 1998 in Kyoto we don't
understand you Americans you expect us
to be poor forever and the Indians said
to him this is never been reported by
the way the Indians said to him when
he's trying to bully them into joining
this madness I said you know you got
rich on fossil fuels now it's our turn
when were as rich as you then we'll talk
about emissions limits that's about 75
years offer India
and so the real deniers today are the
climate ears who refuse to consider that
their case or catastrophe has weakened
while promoting completely unserious
solutions that do little or nothing to
stimulate the energy transition they say
they want their default position
continues to be simple-minded
exaggeration or distortion of every
possible angle and what somebody say
today it's warm today it's global
warming
next week it's going to be really cold
here that'll be climate change right so
that's the distortions and the opinion
polls show that the public has a case of
what I call apocalypse fatigue and so
they've rankly politicized this issue
and demonized any self-criticism even
within its ranks you know there's one
lady Judith curry at Georgia Tech who's
always been in the conventional climate
science community till five or six years
ago she started saying you know I think
maybe we have some things wrong here
and we should rethink some things and by
the way we ought to talk to some of the
climate sceptics instead of screaming at
them well guess what's happened to her
she's been cast into outer darkness by
the science she was the chairman of the
what of the geophysics department at
Georgia Tech person of considerable
scientific chops that's what happens if
you raise at the center doubt finally I
said that there was a third funny thing
that happened and that was the
unexpected revival of oil and gas and I
want to use that to say as I say Robert
Bryce and Mark Mills will talk about
this tomorrow and what's ahead
especially mark who's his degree in
engineering from MIT he really knows the
nitty gritties of this but think about
now and it's true what people said today
what an McElhaney said last night and
what I've just said the
environmentalists are relentless
authoritarians
on the other hand think how depressing
it must be to be environmentalist right
now and to see this surge and natural
gas and oil production going on that's
going to spread around the world right I
mean for the longest time
environmentalists said we've just got to
get to using renewable energy and banana
peels and whatever else because we're
going to run out of oil and coal and gas
anyone remember Peak Oil anyone heard of
Peak Oil lately
and now the problem for environmentalist
is that we're not going to run out of
these fuels anytime soon again ten years
ago environmental czar saying you know
we're for natural gas it's a bridge fuel
they'd say now they're against natural
gas they've gone all John Kerry honest
there were for natural gas before they
were against it
and you have to know environmental
folklore here in a land with this is
recently as nineteen ninety-eight that
was when the first Kyoto treaty was
signed environmentalists thought hey
we're on our way
this Kyoto things going to work in
nineteen ninety nine all the leading
environmental groups in America said the
leading environmental problem of today
is suburban sprawl and that's what they
made a big push in 1999 and 2000 because
they thought well China things that
we've signed a treaty right that's a
particular tick of the liberal mind
right you solve problems by having
signing ceremonies on the White House
lawn and if you had predicted to an
environmentalist in 1998 that not only
would the Kyoto treaty go down in flames
that there'd be a massive revival in oil
and gas the price of natural gas would
go from fourteen dollars down to two it
would suddenly be abundant as far as the
eye can see I think they might have
marched out into the sea and drowned
themselves come to think of it maybe
that's not a anyway I will stop there
and turn to your questions and comments
thank you
I can't see very far anymore so good if
I'll point them out thank you dr.
Hayward we have a couple of microphones
here please raise your hands and stand
up when the microphone gets to you and
also they will hold the microphone for
you thank you just like a classroom
students never want to ask the first
question after Elector there's there's a
brave fellow go sir yeah I have two
questions do you know where 2014 is
targeted to be in terms of the hottest
years on record is it going to be in the
top 10 in the top 20 top 50 yeah at
someone to top 10 or 20 yeah yeah it's
headed to be number one
there's dispute about that well we just
have to wait another six or seven weeks
when the right answer but have you
looked at the hottest months of the year
we look at May in April and June and
July they've been the hottest months in
the planet this year have you followed
that yes if you look at the satellite
data it's not looking that way that's
based on the ground temperature data and
that's a big furious controversy as I'm
sure you must know I understand the data
pretty well and by the way you some so
what by the way I mean so you watch
it'll be the hottest year on record in
the plateau I expect all these years to
be among the hottest the last century
uh-huh why is that news well can you
tell me what evidence you have that
there's been a pause in the warming can
you tell me that evidence I'll be I'll
give you a brief Lee just a little bit
three words
satellite temperature record
very much for your time coming out today
this evening my question is going to be
going back to your talk about dr.
richard lyndon dealing specifically with
climate models in and of themselves what
in your opinion is a specific flaw with
hockey stick crafts and stuff that the
IPCC uses specifically what foster
things such as a cue to protocol in the
UNFCCC and how can we go about
addressing that in today's modern era
thank you sir hold on you have two or
three parts there one was a hockey stick
is that right and then IPCC what I
didn't I didn't quite take it al and now
with your own fast sorry yeah basically
just the climate models themselves what
the flaws are how can we go about
addressing those and hockey stick graph
as one of those models yeah the hockey
sticks not a model that's a temperature
reconstruction based on a whole lot of
called proxy data
I quit following that too after about
the one of the National Academy of
Sciences report on that come out two
thousand seven or eight and that was
before you had the email the whole email
leaks that were so interesting because
what it showed is so many people who'd
worked on that didn't care for Michael
Mann very much at all it's pretty funny
to read those the National Academy of
Sciences put a report out in 2007-2008
about reviewing the hockey stick and
news headlines all said vindicates
hockey stick when I read the report
guess what it said something else to do
this from memory I wrote it all in a
couple of articles and toward the end
they did several things they criticized
man and his collaborators Bradley dinner
guys for not sharing their data not
being transparent second they said -
Academy signed gerald North at Texas was
the guy - they were given the data and
they look through it went through all
the stuff and they said looks to us like
this is only really reliable back about
four hundred years before that we're
making stuff up that's not quite the
language they use but that's what it
said and in their press conference they
were sort of said you know we've
overdone this whole thing and that's
kind of where things were left and then
they say when the emails came out I
wrote two articles about it in the
week-long articles in the Weekly
Standard that just went through saying
look what some of these guys say about
each other and about the limb
tations of their own work it was pretty
revealing and pretty amazing party was a
circle the wagons thing they didn't want
to admit any of those doubts or
uncertainties in her own work so and now
of course Michael Mann is suing National
Review and what's his name mark Stein
right and it's a bizarre suit as a libel
matter and we'll see how this goes I
mean I can't imagine they really want to
get into Discovery on this I don't know
what mans thinking but and is that the
IPA so it was a model that was a
temperature we get what is the past look
like right and yeah the eyepiece I guess
the other point of is the IPCC adopted
or inserted that thing in their 2001
report at the last minute most the
people worked on the Sun never saw it
and that raised a lot of people's iron
because it seemed me put in by the
politicians at the end so someone else
thank you very much for coming on
speaking just a question for you because
you eluded this during your whole speech
but never really explicitly said it how
do you separate the science from the
politics in other words you talked about
the did being described as a belief and
then all of a sudden this one lady was
just going out and saying this is what I
found and then she was actually cast out
how do you separate that how do you find
the truth in all the muck and all of the
political banter yeah that's a good
question so here the question is how do
you separate science and politics I
think is that a fair enough of a summary
here's there's the basic problem and
maybe I should have put it this way
science tells us what is doesn't tell us
what to do about things I mean a
corollary position might be let's go
back 20 let's go back to the late 70s
when by the way if you go back to
newspapers and people then cognitive the
leading environmental problem according
to Jimmy Carter was acid rain let's
study the matter we spent ten years on
napalm national acid precipitation
assessment project it concluded in three
volumes that the problem was real but
overstated then what do you do about it
the report didn't say what to do about
it that's what science ought to be about
is describing how something happens now
what happens here and you know the
people who pump the 97% business-like to
say ah
scientists all agree that were doomed
and therefore we have to have the Kyoto
Protocol most scientists are not very
good at public policy analysis and a lot
of will admit that by the way and a lot
of them ma'am you know there a lot of
them out there
what happens is the noisiest of them
people like Jim Hansen at NASA who I've
debated twice and have come to
conclusions of manic-depressive you know
I think they I don't know it you've
always had you've always had some
scientists and wanted in on the action
that's not true climate it's been true
of a lot of things but that's always a
problem in science and policy and we
don't do a very good job of thinking
about all that someone else somebody
there would like its points that I find
quite interesting if you listen to TV
and they give you home we hit a new
record today the last record was 1935 or
some such time so many records were set
in the 30s and maybe we exceed them by a
point or two by a degree or two I don't
know what was warming it up so much in
the 30s the other point is very short
there's a very good reason they called
Greenland Greenland it was warm
yeah no I mean this is this is what I
call the the groundhog day aspect of the
issue right we go back to some of these
arguments we're having for 20 years now
and there continue to be I'm an a.1 guy
Daniel Bakken who's now emeritus
professor environmental science at UC
Santa Barbara he is going this biggie so
we try and find all these things the
past to try and find out something he's
going through ships logs from the 19th
century up in Hudson Bay this is back
when old British sailors would record
you know what T they had in the morning
right to try and sea ice extent and see
if he can match it up so we're always
trying these clever things to try and
figure out but it only goes back 150 200
years right so there were probably
here's how this happens they were
probably
ten articles published today in the
science journals on some aspect of
climate it's the big field right now
maybe maybe it's 25 and you can't keep
up with them all I try to keep up with
the best I can in nature and science and
some of the summaries but it's
impossible that's why I work on the
policy of it let's assume that again
thought experiment let's assume it's
true Kyoto I mean it's the gentleman was
saying is a bit hot is here you still
haven't given any solution that's in the
real world at all
hi to two different contradictory things
both accurate both lucid in the last
year both in the northern and southern
hemisphere the Arctic and Antarctic ice
flows are melting that's that's true so
far as I understand secondly Toledo Ohio
this last year had more snow than any
time in its recorded snow measuring
history which goes back to approximately
1880 so some things are hotter and some
things are colder your comments that's
why the most climate scientists will say
we have at least in the short run and
even a long run a chaotic system so I
mean the polar vortex say that's not
that unusual I think we had a lot of
those back in the 70s with a lot of
really cold winters in the 70s around
here I don't think we were looking at it
fighting the fine-grain way we are now
for climate reasons yeah now they
haven't looked at the latest ice data
for a year or so I think so we're about
the Arctic ice cap is about I'm going to
say this could be wrong by five about 30
percent below where it was in late 70s
we started satellite measurements and
that was just steadily down then you had
a big drop in 2008 was it and a rebound
and it's not clear yet we haven't added
but this last year looked like we had a
bit of a rebound up so we'll see what
this winter looks like I want to see
that for four or five years for you see
if it's actually reversed trend we have
time for one more question
question I want to ask kind of following
a couple points is you know most most
climatologists in the mainstream tend to
blame carbon dioxide and other
greenhouse gas emissions for causing
temperature aberrations what is kind of
happening with sciences accepting of the
notion that perhaps something else is to
blame I know a Harvard researcher I
believe Willie soon went up to the
Arctic developed some charts and he came
up with theory and several others called
theory that total solar irradiation was
to blame the which sorry total solar
solar irradiation basically solar
activity Sun activity and also I know
some some scientists have attributed to
oceanic oscillations and so you know
given that those theories seem to be
seem to match up with actual temperature
data far better than them carbon dioxide
does is there any growing acceptance in
the scientific community that maybe
these things are factors more than than
human action well the short answer is I
don't know because it's get even I mean
I've used a shorthand of the scientific
community but there's a lot of variation
of scientific community there's a lot of
popularity with yet the ocean
oscillations is a that's a well-known
phenomenon there there is a theory
popular with people like Hansen Jim
Hansen it sounds a lot but black carbon
that that the shrinkage of the Arctic
ice cap owes more to changes in albedo
though that means is the snow is
actually darker doesn't look darker to
us but the Sun and radiation balances
all the rest of that it's darker
therefore absorbs more heat and it melts
now where's that coming from well you
know our cold emissions are China mostly
but not quite sure about that but so
there's a lot of thought on that and you
know that does make a big difference
it's that that turns out to be fairly
easy to control by the without you get
rid of coal I mean we've gotten rid of
our you know we've got scrubbers on our
coal plants China's new coal plants are
much lower emissions and the one have
been building the last 20 years because
they're so bad and so that if that's
true
might be a declining problem the solar
radiation thing has ten different
variations at least and I'd be
hard-pressed to get into great detail
about them and so I just I let them
thrash all that out so that's about the
best I can do on that because there's
there's a you know there's a wide menu
on all of those things oh that's right
you said we're done good yes thank you
very much dr. Hayward
the hospitality the hospitality will
begin here on the mezzanine for our
guests and students you know what to do
hopefully by now thank you what a
student supposed to go away go on the
left oh okay very good yep
you